the other big issue
is the absolute murderous lie that
America remains systemically racist we
know that at one time it was but to
continue acting like it is drives things
like reparations race-based preferences
diversity Equity inclusion but more than
that it's getting people killed it's
called The George Floyd effect or the
Ferguson effect and that's a phenomenon
of cops pulling back from their normal
proactive policing so that in the last
several years there are literally
thousands of people I call them excess
casualties who are dead or who have
suffered from violent crime who
otherwise would not have suffered if the
police had done their normal for active
policing
and the People by the way who are these
excess casualties are the very black and
brown people that people in the left
purport to care about which is a common
theme by the way in my candidacy and
then there's the absolute disaster of
urban education in America where just to
pick two cities
Baltimore 13 public high schools I kid
you not where zero percent of the kids
can do math at grade level another half
a dozen only one percent can Chicago 53
government schools zero percent of the
kids can do math and grade level
Nationwide there's something called the
Americas report card I think it stands
for National assessment of educational
policy the Americas report card 85
percent of black 8th graders these are
13 year old kids can either read nor do
math a grade level half can do basic
reading but the Democratic party because
of their largest fundraiser funder is
the is the teachers union adamantly
oppose a school choice as the elites
like Barack Obama Joe Biden uh uh lizard
Warren send their own kids to private
schools with the nine black and brown
kids the opportunity to do the same
thing even though polls show in the
inner city black and brown parents want
school choice so if I can talk about
those issues get them front and center
days I will feel that I give them back
to my party and more importantly I will
feel that feeling back to my country
thank you
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of the Larry Elder show former
gubernatorial candidate for the once
great state of California and now
candidate for president of the United
States on the Republican side going for
that nomination we'll see my old friend
Larry Elder welcome back to the Reuben
report
Dave thank you so much for having me I
cannot tell you how many people on the
campaign Trail uh particularly young
people tell me that they discovered me
uh when you interviewed me some years
ago
well it goes both ways my friend because
many people discovered me when you beat
me senseless and all that stuff everyone
knows about that is there anything else
you want to say about that moment that
you force-fed me the red pills is there
anything that has not been said about
that at this point
I guess nothing other than this day you
know one of the reasons I'm running is
because of the way we're at each other's
throats we meaning half the country
versus the other half of the country my
mother I think you know this was a
lifelong Democrat she was a regular
feature on my radio show and my damn
lifelong Republican
and ought to be a fly on the wall when
my mom and my dad were arguing about
politics but nobody ever called anybody
a fascist nobody called anybody a Nazi
nobody said you only hear about the rich
you don't care about the poor they
argued civilly I have no idea why we
gotten to the point now we can't do that
yeah and I come from a family with a
very similar background in that regard
it was all over the place politically
argue it out and dessert would be served
and everybody would put it down and and
do it again the next night uh I want to
start today because people do know our
history obviously and know that you're
on the campaign Trail right now I want
to start today with uh when the the
recall did not work out as as you and I
had hoped uh you and Nina came over to
my place I think the next night or two
nights after and you said to me as I
cracked open a bottle of wine Dave I
think I'm gonna run for president of the
United States and I think I said Larry
you crazy bastard and here we are you're
doing it
well and the reason I'm doing it today
was because I am a America first guy I'm
a make America great great Indian guy I
supported Donald Trump in 2016 campaign
for him and with him I supported him
again in 2020 that's not the issue I'm
bringing to the table some things I
think the other side for reasons that I
cannot understand are not talking about
our side or not it's not talking about
number one the epidemic of
fatherlessness it is the ten thousand
pound elephant in the room that the left
doesn't want to talk about because they
caused it our side doesn't want to talk
about it for fear I think
that is perceived as denigrating single
moms who are often heroically raising
kids by themselves or grandparents or
they're afraid of being called
systemically racist or in my case as you
well know afraid of being called the
black face of white supremacy in 1965
somebody didn't mention that up top you
are the black face of white supremacy
according to the LA Times
and I worked harder in their title in
1965 day 25 of black kids into the world
without a father in the home marriage of
the mother now it is 70 today 25 percent
of white kids now enter the home without
a father uh in the into the world
without a father in the home marriage of
the mother and as a consequence of the
welfare state that Democrat Lyndon
Johnson launched in the mid 60s and
since then in my opinion what we've done
is to incentivize women to marry the
government and incentivize men to
abandon their financial and moral
responsibility and these numbers I'm
about ready to cite we're also cited by
Barack Obama so you know they must be
true a kid Israel got a dad at five
times more likely to be poor intimate
crime nine times more likely to drop out
of school and 20 times likely to end up
in jail I've got some ideas about what
we can do about that but no one's
talking about it uh the other big issue
is the absolute murderous lie that
America remains systemically racist we
know that at one time it was but to
continue acting like it is drives things
like reparations race-based preferences
diversity Equity inclusion but more than
that it's getting people killed it's
called The George Floyd effect or the
Ferguson effect and that's the
phenomenon of cops pulling back from
their normal proactive policing so that
in the last several years there are
literally thousands of people I call
them excess casualties uh who are dead
or who have suffered from violent crime
who otherwise would not have suffered if
the police had done their normal or
active policing
and the People by the way who are these
excess casualties are the very black and
brown people that people in the left
purport to care about which is a common
theme by the way in my candidacy and
then there's the absolute disaster of
urban education in America where just to
pick two cities
Baltimore 13 public high schools I hit
you not where zero percent of the kids
can do math at grade level another half
a dozen only one percent can Chicago 53
government schools zero percent of the
kids can do math and grade level
Nationwide there's something called the
Americas report card I think it stands
for National assessment of educational
policy the Americas report card 85
percent of black 8th graders these are
13 year old kids can either read nor do
math a grade level half can do basic
reading but the Democratic party because
of their largest fundraiser funder is
the is the teachers union adamantly
oppose a school choice as the elites
like Barack Obama Joe Biden uh uh lizard
Warren send their own kids to private
schools with the nine black and brown
kids the opportunity to do the same
thing even though polls show in the
inner city black and brown parents want
school choice so if I can talk about
those issues get them front and center
days I will feel that I give them back
to my party and more importantly I will
feel that feeling back to my country
yeah and it's obvious from knowing you
on camera and off camera like How Deeply
you care about these things these are
real to you and the things that you've
been living and talking about on the
radio for three decades before doing it
on the internet now and everything else
I want to jump back to one statistic you
just mentioned because when people hear
this idea I think you said I think you
said if I'm not mistaken 1964 25
of uh black uh children were born in a
one family of one parent home but so the
mother and now it's 70 can you connect
that actually to Democrat policies in a
somewhat simple way so people can really
understand that because I think I think
that they hear the statistic but they
don't fully understand well okay well
how does that really have something to
do with the welfare state so if we could
connect that I think it would be great
if you look at the amount of money that
we spent on the so-called war on poverty
from 1965 until now uh it's around 22
trillion dollars if you look at the
trend line of kids born outside of
wedlock it parallels that trend line uh
so in my opinion there is a um a
connection uh and again it was Lyndon
Johnson the Democrat who launched a
so-called war on poverty and his goal
was to provide a temporary basis for
people to escape poverty I don't believe
he understood that it was going to
create a dependency there was a poll in
the L.A times in the 80s
for people who are poor and on welfare
were asked do you believe that welfare
is a stepping stone towards independence
or do you believe that welfare is a Crux
that makes you dependent Moore called it
a crutch 41 percent than called it a
stepping tone stepping stone towards uh
Independence 31 there's an interesting
book
called The Tragedy of America and
compassion by a guy named Marvin alaski
and he looks at people during the Great
Depression who are eligible for benefits
for the New Deal benefits but for what
whatever reason reasons of pride of
self-sufficiency did not take them and
looked at those families 20 years down
to find out which ones were better and
not too surprisingly the family did not
take the welfare were far better off
than the family that did take the
welfare FDR even called welfare his new
deal uh which he thought was going to be
temporary a quote subtle narcotic close
quote that trash people into dependency
this is an age-old problem uh Alexis
Alexis de tofu excuse me wrote about it
in the book called Memoirs on popularism
he was well he was able to travel around
the world which is unusual in those days
and he went to England which at the time
was the wealthiest country in the world
and he saw that there were many many
beggars on the streets more than
anywhere else he'd been he thought that
was a conundrum it turned out that that
London England was the first state to
provide no questions to ask welfare and
as a result there were far more people
who were dependent on welfare than other
states didn't did not provide it it's
just human nature uh slovenly Behavior
if uh subsidized becomes more slovenly
you see that with homelessness you see
that with all sorts of things and you
certainly see it with with people being
incentivized to have children without a
man being in the home
you know I think I said this when when I
helped campaign with you you know in
some ways it's ironic because I know you
you want to live in a post-racial world
in many ways we do and yet so much of
what you talk about is addressing these
perceived racist issues that there's a
bit of a I suppose a catch 22 in there
um are you worried that no matter how
much you lay out these ideas and and
clearly just from our conversations the
millions of people who have been
enlightened by this stuff you're
affecting a certain amount of people but
that for whatever reason all-time low
black unemployment under Donald Trump uh
that you know black males I think it was
seven percent that voted for Donald
Trump and I think females were four
percent that for whatever reason that
thing has been so lodged that it may be
an intractable problem politically
I don't think so in fact the numbers are
this Donald Trump got eight percent of
the black vote in 2016. uh he got 12 in
2020 a 50 increase but 20 of black males
vote of him and I believe for the reason
that you mentioned best economy ever for
blacks uh he pardoned the first black
heavyweight champion Jack Johnson he did
the first step act that allowed some
almost 50 almost 5 000 mostly black men
have their sentences to be considered
the reduced and average around 70 months
uh he secured the borders of the group
most hurt by illegal alien labor are
black people living in the inner city
because most of the illegal aliens have
very little education so they compete
against them the one study done by the
Civil Rights group found Dave that about
a million more blacks would be working
if it weren't for the presence of
illegal alien labor and illegal alien
labor puts downward pressure to the tune
of almost eighteen hundred dollars per
year and the salaries of people living
in the inner city and Donald Trump
supported school choice which as I
mentioned most black and brown parents
in the inner city won so I think
if you if you lay out the facts lay out
this fact too uh a young black man and I
consider this to be young since I'm 71
years old age 10 to 43 is 13 times more
likely to be murdered than a young white
man in the same demo Nationwide 60 of
the homicides of the shootings and the
robberies were committed by blacks
mostly young black men unless you're
prepared to say that blacks are just
genetically inclined to be criminals you
have to ask yourself what the devil is
going on and I said that to people who
are upset with me when I talk about race
being no longer a major problem in
America what's your analysis of why
black people are doing this and the
answer is the breakdown of the nuclear
intact family you do not find this kind
of criminality when people come from a
nuclear intact families there's a
left-wing publication called the
Atlantic
and a few months ago they had this long
very interesting article about all the
decisions a young couple makes when they
have a kid whether from what what to
name him or her uh would come into to uh
paint the uh the nursery the most
important decision is whether you're
able to live in a neighborhood with a
majority of two parent households even
if you are a single parent household
said the article you're going to benefit
by being around uh families that have
two parents in the household what does
that tell you the most left-wing popular
thing tank in America is a Brookings
institution they have a researcher named
Isabelle Sawhill
s-a-w-h-i-l-l done a lot of research on
the importance of being raised by two
parent households and laid out all the
stats we talked about at the top of your
show yeah it's so interesting my parents
still live in the house that I was
brought up in that they bought in 1979
they've been married over over 50 years
my mom I'm the oldest of three my mom
stopped working when I went to school so
she made us you know breakfast lunch and
and dinner obviously was home when we
came home from school and then when my
sister who's 11 years younger than me
when she was out of school my mom went
back to work and and they have three you
know I'd like to think relatively
functioning children so it's basically
what you're saying is we all know it to
be true but a whole bunch of people are
kind of afraid let's talk a little bit
or at least afraid to say it let's let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
on the campaign because right now uh to
get into the first debate you need 40
000 individual donors you don't quite
have that yet you're on your way there
and I hope that this show will get some
people to chip in and we'll we'll link
to that down below but you you do
qualify by your where you're polling at
so you just need a few more donors to
get in there can you just talk about
what your strategy has been going out
there talking to people I see you on the
ground with a lot of folks all the time
taking questions smiling all kissing
babies all the stuff
well my strategy is to get out as many
programs as yours like yours to tell
people exactly what I need I've done a
lot of thoughts done a lot of Newsmax a
lot of news Nation I just did that
yesterday uh to tell people I need 40
000 individual donors the amount can be
as small as one dollar and all you have
to do is go to my website larryelder.com
the criteria are at least one percent of
the polls and forty thousand individual
donors and frankly uh I'm kind of
surprised it's been that difficult to do
I got three and a half million votes
when I ran for governor on the
replacement Side California has 58
counties that carry 57 the only one I
lost was San Francisco and I lost that
by 149 votes I raised more money than
all of the other 45 rival replacement
candidates come by more than all of the
Republicans uh combined yet it's been
very difficult I think because
because of the presence of trump and the
Senate so I think a lot of people feel
that they're likely to be the nominee
and they don't want to quote waste their
money close quote but as I said earlier
even if you want somebody else at the
very least don't you want me to be
talking about the issue of
fatherlessness the lie that America
systemically races the need for school
choice we also have on our website Dave
a model legislation that states can
adopt to set up commissions of retired
judges retired lawyers to get retired
DA's rather to get rid of these soft on
crime George Soros back DA's they're all
over the place they're in San Francisco
or at least they used to be until the
guy was recalled La been two attempts to
recall George gascon uh in Philadelphia
There's been an impeachment of the
George Soros backdia but the Senate
refused to take up the trial they've got
it in Des Moines Iowa the course they
got one in New York
and this commission would allow citizens
to file complaints and allow the
commission to hear the compliance and if
necessary to recommend the removal of
that the George Soros back D.A and
finally I'm arguing this we've had this
standoff that we have from time to time
on whether or not to raise the debt
ceiling and of course you and I both
know that they have something's going to
be raised because nobody wants to be
responsible for the consequences of what
happens if America defaults on its debt
and from time to time you have a
standoff on whether or not the
government ought to be shut down and
whatever it has been which it has been
in a few times in the last few years the
party that is received as
blameworthy gets hurt in the polls so I
think going forward it's not likely
we're going to be shutting down the
government even either over over funding
the only way to rein in spending because
much of it is on automatic pilot because
of the so-called entitlements is with an
amendment to fix spending to a certain
percentage of the GDP with exceptions
for war and for natural disaster
otherwise both parties are going to
spend government grew under Ronald
Reagan it grew under George Herbert
Walker Bush it grew under George W bush
it grew under Donald Trump
and and won't any politician that runs
promising to reform Social Security or
reform Medicare or reform Medicaid you
will lose elections which is why the can
is always kicked down the road the word
unsustainable to describe the uh
so-called entitlement was used by Bill
Clinton and Barack Obama yet nothing
gets done because you'll be hammered
you'll be killed you'll be massacred in
the polls if you do but if you are
forced to do so by law you can then come
out from the room and say the devil
maybe do it please don't hurt me at The
Ballot Box so I know the stuff that that
sort of your red meat and the stuff that
you love talking about and that you've
been you know hitting hard for all these
years when you're when you're out there
when you're in Iowa New Hampshire and
some of these early States now what's
what's kind of the temperature of of the
people on the right the Republicans as
they're getting visits from all you guys
now
the economy the economy the economy
people are concerned about inflation
they're concerned about gas prices
they're concerned about crime uh and
they're concerned about the borders I
think those are the primary issues uh
that people are concerned about uh and
people feel pushed around they feel that
Donald Trump has been subjected to a a
two-tiered Judicial System they're angry
over Donald Trump being indicted over
the documents but Joe Biden is still
being investigated I believe that O.J
Simpson will find the killer of killers
of Ron and Nicole before the 100 by
investigation has been completed and
people are angry about anybody that
dares suggests that if you raise
questions about 2020 you are an election
denier even as Hillary for the entirety
president Trump's term referred to him
as illegitimate said the election was
stolen with far less evidence I think
people are concerned about that but by
and large people are worried about
dinner table issues most notably the
fact that their wages are not keeping up
with inflation of the high gas prices
and overall the economy I think about
two-thirds of Americans if not more
believe that we're on the wrong track
yeah what are people saying about the
Democrats right now because I'd imagine
everybody sort of isn't into Biden but
I'm I'm guessing you're probably also
hearing from some sort of moderate
Democrats who are kind of thinking oh
maybe this is the year to break away
because they're so bananas right now
well you you would hope hope so I think
a lot of people Republicans I talked to
feel Democrats are just absolutely crazy
they feel that they're obsessed with
things like like climate change they
hear Joe Biden give a speech at Howard
University and say the number one threat
to the Homeland is white supremacy and
they just wonder who these people are
you know my mom as I mentioned was a
lifelong Democrat but I got her to vote
for republicans in latter years she
voted twice for George W bush and she's
one of those Democrats who believe I
didn't leave the party the party left me
but she refused to change her party
registration for I think emotional
reasons
let's jump back to to Cali for a sec
because that is where you still live
you're still in Cali still in Los
Angeles and I know you've got a good
life there and everything else I
desperately tried to get you to flee
with me do you think that Cali la
specifically but all these blue cities
that were watching sort of In The Free
Fall do you think there is a comeback
for them or do you think that they just
have not hit rock bottom yet and there's
just more to go
you know I've written a book about uh my
my California race and what the
one-party state has done uh to the state
as you know we've got super majorities
of Democrats in the assembly uh and in
the Senate so Republicans need not even
show up for work and they pass one job
killing bill after another one Freedom
sapping bill after another is called as
goes California my mission to rescue the
Golden State and save the nation my
goals are modest and I I again I liken
it to a drug addict at some point you
would think the voters would hit rock
bottom and began to rethink their
assumptions and put different people in
office but it's not happening you know
the the recall part lost by a pretty
substantial margin a guy named Caruso
ran against Karen Bass the black female
Democrat who was elected mayor of La he
outspent her ten to one lifelong
developer had great ideas about what to
do about the homeless and he got crushed
and I thought maybe there might be a
chance to given the crime in La given
the homelessness in La given the fact
that the average price of a home in
California 175 percent above the
national average uh the poor schools I
thought maybe just maybe there would be
a chance that the voters would find
somebody that they could get around I
saw the debates very confident debater
uh he got he got crushed so I I really
don't know I don't think we're there yet
you know I I thought maybe when the
crime went to the suburbs maybe
something would happen uh a few years
ago a retired Motown Mogul in his 80s
married to a woman in her 80s uh listen
to Beverly Hills has armed security at
his house Dave guy broke in who never
should have been on the streets and shot
and killed the woman then shortly after
that a UCLA graduate student working in
a store in Hancock Park uh the very Tony
area of La where Maxine Waters has her
five million dollar mansion
that's where she has her mansion
well it used to be her district and now
the district changed and the rules are
you can keep your house where you used
to have it so technically she hasn't
violated any law but anyway UCLA
graduate student uh was working at a
furniture store a guy comes in homeless
guy shouldn't have been on the streets
with a knife kills her and uh I would
have thought that maybe just maybe when
the crime comes to the bird something
would happen with these Elites that are
sending all this money uh to people like
Gavin Newsom but it still hasn't
happened so at some point according to
my a former next door neighbor Mrs plus
things don't always keep getting bad
forever so at some point uh the lust
Factor has got to kick in but I don't
know when that's going to be
we only have a couple minutes left let's
just talk a little bit about the uh the
ins and outs of what's going on with the
Republicans because you mentioned the
big two obviously it's it's Trump and
DeSantis as you're watching them kind of
go at each other
you know you can sort of somewhat sit it
out but what do you make of the the
Brewing War there it's a damn shame it's
a damn I mean you know where I'm at kind
of and how I fled so publicly to Florida
but I do support Trump I love you like
you know I want you on that debate stage
and all this stuff but what do you make
of just like the war that's Brewing
right now is this just politics and we
all got to get past it
well we should understand that the
target is the Harris by the
administration notice I said Harris
Biden because if Joe cannot fog up a
mirror it's going to be Kamala Harris
and after he gets crossed across the
Finish Line he's going to hand over the
Baton to her so that's what the target
is and during the recall campaign you
might recall I never said a single
negative thing about my Republican
Rivals Unfortunately they did not abide
by the same tenant had they done so had
they done what I always did when I was
given a chance to take a shot at uh John
Cox or Kevin uh Faulkner that's a
two-term mayor of San Diego that the
establishment party won in California to
win by the way I took San Diego County
by 30 points just saying when I had a
chance to take a shot at Caitlyn Jenner
I always said they're not the issue the
issue is Gavin Newsom ask Gavin Newsom
at what point does he feel if pregnancy
has gone so far that it constitutes
homicide ask Gavin Newsom why he hasn't
put his own kids in public school ask
Gavin Newsom why he was jumping it up at
the French Laundry with the people that
drafted the mandates not not wearing a
mask not engaging in Social distancing
same thing here the target is the
inflation the target is the crazy
borders we're going to have about 8
million illegal aliens in the country by
the end of his first term Lord knows how
many more by the end of his second term
uh the war on oil and gas has caused our
gas prices to go up all the spending the
illegal debt forgiveness uh and the in
the denigration of police officers
he's a Target and so any one of these
candidates would be superior to the
Harris by the administration we got we
have a really deep bench and we ought to
be proud of proud of that and I am you
know hearing you talk about how you
behaved and you're the way you did not
attack the other guys on your side of
the aisle during that campaign it
reminds me that two or three days before
the recall that uh what was his name the
Reed Hastings from Netflix was pouring
millions and millions of dollars in
essence calling you a white supremacist
and you know your Trump evil blah blah
blah and then they sent Biden and Obama
to Cali to campaign for Gavin and they
refused to even say your name you
remember that right oh yeah and Joe
Biden said well Joe Biden said my name
he said Larry he's the closest thing to
a Donald Trump that I've ever seen that
wouldn't say your name yeah
the closest thing to a trump clone that
I've ever seen uh should I be flattered
or should I be offended Larry reminding
people for a moment Donald Trump came
from his dad worth obviously like
hundreds of millions your dad was a
janitor if I'm not mistaken probably not
worth hundreds of Millions
my dad never knew his biological father
was kicked out of the house by his
irresponsible mom and he was 13 years
old Athen Georgia Jim Crow South at the
beginning of the Great Depression he
ended up when I was growing up cleaning
toilet two full-time jobs cleaning
toilets cooked for a family on the
weekend because he wanted my mom to be a
stay-at-home mom went to night school to
get his GED then went to night school to
learn how to operate a small restaurant
started a small restaurant in his late
40s ran it until his 80s my dad retired
he owned the restaurant he owned a
little bit of property next door plus
the home that's still in our family not
too shabby for somebody who really faced
brutal racism when he was growing up
that's why I have so little tolerance
for the way Democrats are trying to tell
black people that they remain oppressed
it is nonsense the formula to escape
poverty uh is pretty uh straightforward
finish High School don't have a kid
until you get married get married first
get a job keep that job don't quit that
job to get another job and avoid the
criminal justice system do that you will
not be poor and that is what Democrats
ought to be telling young black people
instead of telling them people owe you
something people owe you preparation
which in my opinion
is a fraction of money from people who
are never slave owners to be given to
people who are never slaves the
Democratic party has pimped black people
for decades they need that night that
nearly 90 95 monolithic Black Folk
without which they cannot win at the top
and so rather than get black people
talking about bad schools and crime uh
and jobs they got them talking about
social justice excuse me and Equity
whatever the devil those things mean
Larry you are a colleague a mentor and
most importantly a friend I'm honored to
have been on this journey with you and
let's get you to those 40 000 so the
link is right down below and I wish you
luck my friend
we've got company to say thanks Dave as
always I appreciate it God bless
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell